so this is
2022 poll
s
uh just this is a bunch of different
ways to look at the same basic effect in
the United States
Democrats younger Americans identified
dealing with climate change is the top
priority U.S adults
42 say uh 42 say that dealing with
climate change should be a top priority
11 of Republicans 65 percent of
Democrats and we could see this effect
throughout uh
46 percent of Americans say human
activity contributes a great deal to
climate change by the way this is a
little bit different than what we're
discussing I was uh just looking through
different polls
in the public there seems to still be an
uncertainty about the how much humans
contribute to climate change
more than
scientifically it would only be 24 that
disagree with the U.N climate panel
right three three quarters would agree
are you uncomfortable about the 29 I I
know 29 is actually it's exactly right I
mean okay well everyone doesn't say it's
all well they say that could be the
Border case but anyway this is
interesting but to me across all these
polls if you look Republican versus
Democrat yeah Republican
um it's say that 17 say it's a great
deal Democrats say 71 say it's a it's a
great deal and you just see this
complete division
I think you probably
pandemic
uh you know you can ask a lot of
questions like this do masks work are
they an effective method to slow
transmission of a pandemic you'll
probably have the same kind of polls
about Republicans and Democrats and um
while the effectiveness of masks to me
is a scientific question but
um so there's different truths here
apparently one is a scientific truth
uh one is a truth
held by the scientific Community which
seems to be also different than the
scientific truth sometimes uh and the
other is the public perception that has
that's uh polluted or affected by
political affiliation and then there's
uh whatever is the
uh narrative that's communicated by the
the media they will also have a question
the answer to the question of whether
masks work or not and they will also
have an answer to the question about all
these climate related things so that's a
long way of asking the question of what
how is politics mixed into all of this
on the communication front on the
figuring out what the right policy is
front on the friction of humanity
in the face of the right policies well
I've written a ton on this after I had
that conversion about the social science
when 2006 I began digging in a lot more
on how people hold the leaves and what
they do as opposed to what they think
and
questions about polling and there's two
things that come to me that make me not
worry about the basic literacy like is
is climate change X percent of whatever
I don't really care about that and I'll
explain why
um for one thing
more science literacy more basic
literacy like what is a greenhouse gas
all that stuff Dan cahane a k-a-h-a-n at
Yale he's actually a law school
the last decade he did all this work in
what he calls cultural cognition
which is and he did uh studies that
showed
you know how what you believe
emerges based on culture based on your
background you know your red blue
your where you are in the country
and one of the one of the really
disturbing findings was
that the people who have the most basic
science literacy like who know the most
about
greenhouse effect or whatever
they're at both ends of the spectrum of
views on climate dismissives and alarmed
Steve coonan as I mentioned is a good
example he's brilliant physicist
and he knows every all the science and
he's completely at the end of skepticism
um will happer Who was
close to being Trump's science advisor
was even more out there and he's on
they're both on the uh Jason committee
that advises the government on big
strategic things
um and people at the who are really
alarmed about it also have the same
belief so as a journalist I was thinking
do I just spend my time writing more
explanatory
stories that explain the science better
no do I dig in on this work to
understand what brings people together
and then these same surveys the same
science shows you
if you don't make it about climate among
other things this becomes
you don't have to worry about this
anymore if you could Google for Google
for no red blue divide climate revkin
you'll find a piece I did with some
really good graphs essentially it shows
that in America this is the Yale group
again the uh their climate communication
group there's no red blue divide on
energy Innovation none we need more
climate energy clean energy Innovation
there wasn't even a divide
country bias state by state on
whether CO2 should be regulated as a
pollutant
but it's all like what are the questions
you ask if you ask about
Innovation if you ask about more and
more incentives for Renewable Power
Oklahoma Iowa you know I did a piece
when I was at propublica showing that
the 17 states that were fighting Obama
in court over his clean power plan
we're actually the majority of them were
actually meeting the targets that the
clean power plan had
because they're expanding wind power
already not because of the climate
because it makes money sense and energy
sense so you don't think there's a
political divide in this there is on
climate if you call it climate if you
say it's a climate do you believe in the
climate crisis you're not asking
what kind of energy future do you want
in your town
and so if you if you ask that question
the polarization goes away well I guess
I'm asking is there polarization on
policy no well well there again
the bipartisan infrastructure law that
was passed last November that was
bipartisan
all of Congress said yes and that's a
trillion dollars
several hundred billion of which are for
cleaner energy and resilience
yeah but that
but it's not a climate Bill and it
wasn't a tax
it's it's a it's a it's a it's
incentives so the word climate and
similar words are just used as part of
the signaling like masks it's it's
absolutely it's not as Dan cahane's work
the guy at Yale um he really
demonstrated powerfully abortion gun
rights
um climate
in a more parse level nuclear power
has enduring camps that for and against
what what why do the camps form
some of its cultural cognition it's how
you grew up it's what you fear there's
no common human frame because of like
like folks like certain individuals like
Al Gore
ah like he would make a film he cares
about this thing he's a Democrat
therefore I hate this thing that
therefore I don't like this thing yeah
oh sure yeah you know when people get
attached to an issue if that's what pops
into your head
when you hear climate then and it got
politicized it became
emblematic
and and the you know the whole vaccine
thing
I mean I'm not American so I should stay
a little bit out of this but I think uh
it seems to me that a lot of the thing
that people believe and talk about is
really about what they worry that that
will lead to in terms of policy down the
line so a little bit like do masks work
I'm I'm sort of imagining I don't know
whether this is true but I think part of
it is if I say masks work they're gonna
force me to wear it for the next year so
it doesn't work because then I don't
have to wear it kind of thing that it's
really uh uh you're you're looking much
further down the line and certainly on
climate it seems to me that a lot of the
people who say it's not real it's not
because they don't know it's of course
it's real but it's that they don't want
you to then come and regulate it pretty
heavily yeah so it's because they don't
like top-down government yeah and also
because they don't want another tax and
you know that there's lots of of so it's
it's really it's not a science it's not
a straight science question it really is
a question what do you want to do and
that's where I think Andy you're much
much more right in saying we should you
know have that discussion so what do you
want to do because that will be a much
easier conversation to say do you want
to do really smart cheap stuff or do you
want to do pretty dumb expensive stuff
when you put it that way you you can get
most people on board of course it's not
as simple as that I know and it gets
back to what you said earlier that again
you talked about collaborative
cooperation or whatever
there's a guy at Columbia Peter Coleman
who runs this thing called the difficult
conversations Laboratory
yeah yeah that's awesome and when I
first heard about it I was like oh man
we need that you know and uh his
background's the psychology and uh
conflict resolution mostly at the global
scale related to
atrocities the countries are trying to
get over and
um and there's there's a science to how
to hold a better conversation is you
either through experience or whatever no
um you could if you hold a debate like I
wouldn't want to be in a debate with
Bjorn we could find lots of things we
disagree on but that's that takes it
back to the win-lose model right who
want that's not how you make progress
and what Peter
what I what I learned absorbed from him
Peter Coleman
because I was thinking like we need room
for agreement I need to build a room for
agreement my blog and at the times and
then the stuff I do now you know it's
like how can we talk
and come to agreement he says no no you
don't want agreement you want
cooperation
that allows you to hold on to your
beliefs
but to we're good you know we can
disbelieve it we can disagree on all
these things but let's cooperate on that
one thing
and that's that's a really valuable
distinction that's needed so much in
this Arena because
as I said earlier you can parse it right
down to
the home menu of things Joe manchin
wanted you know transmission lines
you're now we're going to have big
fights over transmission lines we've got
billions of dollars to spend expanding
America's grid
in every community in America is going
to say not here so how do you
Foster a federal local dialogue that
allows that to happen if you want to
have any hope of a better grid
um so that's like
that those insights come from behavioral
sciences that I think are completely
under
valued um in this area Pilkey loves to
quote uh I can't I think it's liberate
but oh Walter Lipman Lipman yes that uh
democracy is not about you know
everybody agreeing but it's about
different people disagreeing but doing
the same one thing yeah together yes I
mean agreeing that we're going to do
this thing so you can disagree but still
do a thing you know possibly for very
different you know uh
there's an amazing video clip that shows
this so powerfully
2015 was the build up to the Paris talks
that led to the Paris agreement you know
this
and a really talented journalist at CNN
at the time John Sutter who's from
Oklahoma originally he um
he saw another Yale study that was a
county by county study of American
attitudes on global warming like right
down to the county level and there's
this little glowing
data point in Woodward County West uh
Oklahoma Woodward County Oklahoma was
Ground Zero for climate skepticism
climate denial what everyone call it
and he's like oh I'm gonna go there and
he went there just as a just to meet
people on the street talk to them about
energy and weather and
he did these little interviews and
there's this one with this guy who's
like a middle-aged Oil Company employee
like a business like a administrator
Thai Thai kind of guy
and he he starts out the interview and
the guy is saying like you know you know
God controls the environment
and if you're watching this you're going
okay this is going to be interesting and
the backstory by the way is the guy he
he paid for the local uh playground to
have dinosaurs and people like toy
dinosaurs and people on the playground
Because he believes in creation you know
six thousand a year creation yeah so so
that's the guy right and and then he
gets to energy and the guy says you know
the same guy who believes God controls
the environment
says you know we have half of our roof
covered with solar panels and we want to
get off the grid entirely
and when I show this I show this to
audiences I say just pause and think
about that for a second
if you went why do you think that's
happening and it's because he's
independent he wants to have his own
source of power he's libertarian he
doesn't want the government telling what
to do he would never vote for Hillary I
guarantee you this is 2015.
but he wanted to get off the grid
entirely to be his own
to be to be himself and so then I say
okay so if you were going around the
country with your climate crisis placard
and you go to Woodward County
do you think that would be a productive
way to go to that place and make your
case
and the answer is pretty obvious no if
you go in there and you listen like
listening is such an important property
that we all forget including journalists
um you much more have to find a path to
cooperation
you could talk to him about
I guarantee if I went there today maybe
I should go to talk about this new bill
370 billion dollars how do we make that
work you know at the local level
how do we answer that guy at the energy
Department [ __ ] Shaw so how do we put
this to work to get our buses off
electricity to get electrified or
transition our street lamps and stuff
you could have a good chat with them if
you go in there say I'm here to debate
you to death on global warming
forget about it